he grew up poor and was the first in his
family to go to college he became
Fortune magazine's
2011 business Person of the Year he's
one of the richest men in America with a
net worth of 1.5 billion dollars
he's Howard Schultz and here his top ten
rules for success I feel so strongly
that the reason I'm here is I dreamed
big dreams I dreamed the kind of dreams
that other people said would not be
possible I'm also living proof this
isn't a Hollywood movie
I count literally from the other side of
the tracks if you saw where I grew up
and we took a picture of it the
neighborhood the setting you say it's
not it's impossible that someone could
come from there and get here
but it is possible and not to sound too
trite it's possible because we still
live in a country where the
entrepreneurial spirit is so alive and
so well and anyone in this country if
you dream big and surround yourself with
great people and leave your ego at the
door and share a success with others and
have a little luck along the way you can
do anything but there will be people
along the way and I remember this who
will say to you you know you're dreaming
too big it's not possible those things
just can't happen don't allow anyone
friend family acquaintances teachers
whoever it is don't allow anyone to tell
you that what you are dreaming for
yourself and your family is not possible
it is possible don't be one of those
people 20 years from now are going to be
walking around a nine-to-five job
miserable and angry and bitter because
you let your dreams get away from you
because you did not believe stronger
enough strongly enough in yourself and
what was possible don't allow that to
happen
this is an unbelievable time and I can't
encourage you enough to continue to
think that things are possible and that
your dreams can come true how many
people have you met in your life who
have said things like I had that idea I
knew about that or I I was so close but
I gave up I think sometimes the
difference between success and failure
winning and losing is a very fine line
between those people who continue to
move forward in August of 87
we had 11 stores and a hundred employees
in a dream to create a national retail
company around the coffee experience
good coffee in America but there was
another dream I had and that was to
build a different type of company a
company that potentially could achieve
the delicate balance between
profitability and the fiscal
responsibility of building shareholder
value but the balance of also having a
heart benevolence and integrating a
social conscience in everything the
company would do and hopefully one day
remember this was 87 the company would
be known as much for its values its
culture its guiding principles as it
would the quality of its coffee fast
forward from 87 to 89 and 80 and 1990
the company was beginning to get some
traction we had about 50 stores we still
were not making money and I think we all
realized at the time that we were not in
the coffee business serving people but
we were in the people business serving
coffee that if we wanted to exceed the
expectations of the customer we had to
first exceed the expectations of our
people we made a very important
strategic decision early on that
franchising could not maintain the
culture and values of the company that
all it would be would be an access to
cheap capital and so we continued on
track of opening and building a company
own system I said for years that that
you
to celebrate your victories and really
celebrate your mistakes and what I mean
by that is that you have to learn from
the mistakes that you make and you've
got to create an environment where
people are not afraid to take a risk and
not afraid to do things that are beyond
what the expectations are at the same
time you got to set up a framework for
how those things are managed and judge
and evaluate but I believe very strongly
that we could build a different kind of
company I never believed never I think
it would have been arrogant to believe
that we could have a thousand 2,000 or
7,500 stores in the US and around the
world but something really magical
started happening and it started
happening as a result of not advertising
or conventional consumer classical
marketing the fact is that Starbucks
spends very little on traditional
advertising it started happening because
we demonstrated to ourselves and now the
world that to build an enduring
sustainable long-term business and
consumer brand it's not about fancy
marketing it's about establishing a very
powerful and unusual emotional
relationship with the customer but I'm
also here to tell you that I feel
strongly that long-term value for your
shareholders cannot be achieved in an
enduring sustainable way unless the
management of the company is completely
and comprehensive ly committed to
creating long-term value for the
employees and the two are directly
linked together and any company any
management team that turns its back on
its people and doesn't share the success
of the company
with the people who do the work are not
going to finish the race I think
something that has happened the last
couple of years that I have noticed
which I think is powerful and it is a
sea change is that the consumer has
begun in many ways to perform what I
would call loosely a cultural audit of
companies of brands and a
products and services that they are
asked to support to buy and the cultural
audit goes something like for the first
time businesses recognize that there is
parity in the marketplace parity on
price parity on features and benefits in
the consumer as a result of that has
significant choices as to what they're
going to buy and support but for the
first time they're asking questions
beyond the characteristics of the
product or the service they're asking
about values
they're asking questions about how you
take care of your people whether or not
you're giving back to the community in
which they live and work I think that
success in business is a very difficult
thing to achieve and it's more difficult
today probably than any other time
despite the vast number of opportunities
and as it relates to finding your
calling in terms of what the opportunity
or the entrepreneurial adventure is
going to be it has to be linked to
something that you are so passionate and
crazed about that you're willing to
knock down walls and climb mountains and
do the things that are going to put
yourself in a position of sacrificing so
many other things for its success and
you can only do that when there's a
compelling underlying feeling that you
have that this is something I'm going to
fight to the death for and without that
I think it's going to be a commodity
based experience not only for the
customer but for you and I think you
can't really succeed at the levels that
you want to unless you find that thing
that you're so passionate excited and in
love with and I think because you've got
it along the way you're going to have to
convince so many other people to believe
in you and the idea and the opportunity
and the struggle and the obstacles that
are going to come can over only be
overcome by this passion that you have
in which you're going to be able to get
people to follow you over the over those
hurdles I know it sounds a little bit
sophomoric but it's so true this is the
key
of unlocking the success of our business
and hopefully the businesses that you
either are thinking about working for or
a part of and it's this it's so basic we
all want the same thing break break away
the differences between what I just
described language politics the way
people dress their history it doesn't
matter we all want the same thing we
want to be respected as employees we
want to be appreciated as customers we
want to feel dignified in the workplace
and who we are as people and we want to
go into a store and for that brief
moment of whether we're buying a cup of
coffee or whatever it might be we want
some value for our money and the human
condition of all of that between
business and the consumer and everything
everything everything else in between
is the human condition of the human
spirit if you can exceed the
expectations of your people if they feel
they're working in an enterprise or a
company that values them as human beings
and not as paychecks values em as human
beings and not a line-item on the
balance sheet and they in turn can take
that feeling of being respected and
appreciated as an employee and share
that with someone else a paying customer
whether it's in Kuwait or Dubai or the
opening of Starbucks France where people
said it wouldn't be possible it can work
and it is sustainable because the human
spirit has no language
and at a time in the world when there is
such cynicism and a fracturing of trust
if you reach out and appreciate and
respect another human being it comes
back to you
you
because not every decision is an
economic despite the fact that the site
statistics that are narrowing crime we
did provide a 38% shareholder return
over last year I don't know how many
tension invested but I would suspect not
many things companies products
investments have been termed 38% of less
of us having said that it is not an
economic decision the lens in which we
are making that decision is through the
lens of our people we have we employ
over 200,000 people in this company and
we want to embrace diversity
thus estimate that you can get a higher
return than 38% you got last year is a
free country you can sell your share
Starbucks advice thank you so much for
watching I made this video because Catan
jij 95 asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do and I'd also love to
know what are the top 10 lessons from
Howard you love the best leave it below
I'm going to joining the discussion and
I'll see you soon